this is a four-leaf clover it's one of
the most well-known good luck charms in
the world in the 1600s it was thought to
be able to ward off witches and
mischievous Spirits later it was said
that if you found a four-leaf clover
you'd meet your soulmate the very next
day nowadays it's a more generic good
luck charm but how did this little plant
become Lucky in the first place
[Music]
hello this is usually where I would put
a sponsored segment but I don't have one
this month so this video is brought to
you by my patreon go to patreon.com
generalistpapers or follow the link in
the description if you want patreon only
updates Early Access to videos and more
or if you just want to support me and
the work I do thanks a lot now back to
the video
[Music]
the Clover or Shamrock has been an
important national symbol of Ireland for
centuries the term Shamrock comes from
the Gaelic word simrog which means
little or young Clover there is an
argument over which Clover species the
word specifically refers to with the Two
Front Runners being the white clover and
the suckling Clover my vote is for the
white clover because of the Shamrock's
prominence as a national symbol it can
be assumed that the folklore surrounding
clovers originates here in Ireland and
by the way a shamrock only refers to the
three leafed clover not a four-leafed
one that being said the Shamrock only
became a national symbol of Ireland in
the 17th century this is granted a long
time ago but if you're like me you
probably expected it to be a more
ancient tradition well writings about
the Shamrock from this time do seem to
refer to the Clover in a way that
suggests the plant had been an important
part of Irish culture for longer in a
example of this is the story of Saint
Patrick
the most famous Irish legend about the
Shamrock involves Saint Patrick he is
the patron saint of Ireland and was the
man who brought Christianity to the
Irish Celts in the 5th Century who up to
that point were pagans there are many
Legends surrounding the man
one sees him raising multiple people
from the dead another says he drove all
the snakes out of Ireland but the legend
of the Shamrock is the one we're
concerned with today you see St Patrick
sometimes had difficulty converting the
local Irish to his faith they were
religious people themselves and The
Druids their Priestly class were
famously good at rhetoric and
argumentation one of the concepts that
was difficult to understand was the
Trinity how can you are one God be three
people the Celts would ask Saint Patrick
picked up a clover from the ground which
was said to be a sacred plant to The
Druids and used it to explain the
Trinity each of the Petals of this plant
represents one person of the Holy
Trinity he would say the Father the Son
and the Holy Ghost but it is still one
plant
this analogy which is still often used
today in Sunday schools was apparently
enough to convince many of the pagans to
convert to the Christian religion
so did this story actually happen
probably not the tale first appeared in
1726 when a botanist Caleb threckheld
wrote A Treatise on the native plants of
Ireland in it he mentioned the story of
Saint Patrick and the Shamrock it is
almost certain the story predates this
text in oral history's past down
Generations but we don't know when it
originated also there's no evidence the
Irish Druids held the Clover in any
special regard this might be surprising
as it is often a fact parroted in many
books and essays but despite many an
article claiming this there isn't any
real proof of it this is actually true
of much of what we think we know about
the Celtic pagans as they didn't leave
much writing behind at all it was during
the Romantic Era that many of the myths
surrounding the ancient Celts were made
up also the Irish pagans already had
multiple Triune deities from the goddess
Brigid who was sometimes one goddess and
sometimes three sisters and the Morrigan
who likewise came either as one or three
so it's unlikely that they would have
been overly confused about the trinity
so that explains the Shamrock and why
it's an important symbol for the Irish
but what about the four-leaf clover the
subject of today's video
well the earliest mention of the lucky
four-leaf clover is from an English
writer and politician named Sir John
Melton in 1620 he wrote If a man walking
in the fields find any four-leaved grass
he shall in a small while after find
some good thing
again it's almost certain that this
Superstition predates this piece of
writing by this point the Clover had
become an important symbol for the Irish
and was seen as a special plant in the
British Isles and because finding a
four-leaf clover is exceedingly rare and
anything rare is seen as special and
auspicious this Superstition evolved
into what we know today
but how rare is a four-leafed clover
really
it's often said that one in every ten
thousand clovers has four leaves but
more recent scientific Studies have
found it to be a bit more common about
one in every five thousand an average
patch of clovers has only a couple
hundred flowers so finding a four-leaf
clover is indeed very uncommon
so if you find one make sure to keep it
it might just bring you good luck
thanks for watching my video if you'd
like to support me and what I do please
consider donating to my patreon the link
is in the description and don't forget
to like And subscribe bye
[Music]
thank you